balloon high above the U.S. We
reported on earlier is not the
only object in the sky people
are talking about tonight.
We just got this new image in of
a historic event, a green comet
that has not been visible in the
sky since the stone age, about
50,000 years ago, recently
photographed above stonehenge in
England.
It is a rare and historic treat
to see it.
I'm joined by Adam frank,
professor of physics.
How significant is this comet,
and did you get a chance to see
it yourself?
>> The thing that's really cool
about this is time.
If you think about the comet as
like a clock, then the last time
that the hands were pointing to
where it is now was the ice age,
essentially, when there was two
miles of ice above my head and
the entire world's population
could fit into Cleveland.
What this shows us is these
comets are visitors from the
dawn of time in many ways.
It's such an amazing thing to
think about the last time this
comet went by, it was all
forests, and now it's New York
City and tiktok.
>> Well, I missed it last time
and this time, so now I have to
wait another 50,000 years?
>> Well, a comet like this, it's
possible this comet is going to
leave, that actually
interactions with Jupiter or
Saturn are going to give it just
enough energy that it's never
coming back.
>> It was just discovered last
March, so how common is it to
discover something that old?
>> Well, there's two kinds of
comets.
There's the one that is come
around less than every 200 years
like haileys, every 75 years or
so.
But these comets are so far out
that you really only catch them
once.
You catch them the first time
that they're coming in because
often they'll fall into the sun,
or once they're gone, they're
not coming back forever or
50,000 years.
It's this new telescope
technology that can pick up
faint objects in the sky as they
change position.
It's taking pictures of the
entire sky every night.
It's because of that transient
telescope that we're able to
catch more of these.
Soon we'll be catching a lot
more of these intruders from the
solar system.
>> I understand the comet can be
differentiated from the stars
because it has that dust and
energized particles around it as
well as something called a green
coma surrounding it.
What exactly is a coma in this
context, and where does the
green come from?
>> So a comet is basically a
giant mountain of mush, of
frozen mush, and as it comes in
towards the sun, it heats up,
and as it heats up, the ices
begin to melt and vaporize.
So the coma is sort of this gas
and plasma that's surrounding
the comet that just recently
went from the ice state to the
gas state.
And the green comes from light
from the sun ripping apart
molecules like cyanide or
carbons -- two carbon atoms
glued together, so that green
hue is telling you the surface
of the comet is being torn apart
from the intense light from the
sun.
>> Again, if you missed it this
time, it may not exist in a few
more years because it may get
torn apart.